I feel like it's weird cuz it happened
on on Easter Saturday for Orthodox
Easter Saturday and I really feel like I
didn't get pasta like there's no Easter
this year that's kind of how it feels
and I'm still kind of in the cave you
know I'm still down we're still kind of
down in that in that cave and so so
that's kind of how it feels but um yeah
at the same time it's been amazing you
know it's been amazing it's been amazing
to see all these people that have
supported us financially are so many
messages prayers people you know it's
just been that's been just astounding
for me very touching and encouraging
just wants you to not crumble and just
keep going and and so and I'm not a very
practical person which is one of my you
know like that really because I'm a
carver they think that I'm a very that
I'm a practical guy but uh but uh but no
IIIi can carve the most precise little
miniature but I'll if I cut the board
for my carving I'll make half an inch
mistake that's how it is for me so so I
yeah so it's so so now like going back I
was just there yesterday and then a few
days ago
stripping more stuff for my workshop you
know putting up fans and then
decontaminating with all these chemicals
and stuff and just it's just so counter
nature to me it's good for me but it's
it's uh if we have to kick myself to get
to something like that now is it settled
that you can move back into that area
and we have a catch-22 situation it's
it's that we actually probably have to
go back because what happens is the
government usually the law that was
passed a few years ago was that if your
your flooded and it's a it's a floatable
hairlike it's a lake that floods your
house and if you have the the government
will not let you rebuild or if you
accept like if you accept a certain
amount to rebuild then if it floods
again they won't give you anything so
they'll give you an amount it's like a
set amount it
it ends up being maximum 250,000
Canadian and you leave that's it you
demolish your house you're gone but
because there's so many people flooded
and because it was a dike they they made
us into an exception so they've said
although it will be considered floodable
area although all of this is true we're
giving you the right to still go back
and rebuild and you have to do it fast
because in six months then you won't be
allowed to rebuild the way that you've
rebuilt Wow and so which means that now
we had we had our kids in the basement
and so they'll be in a floatable area
like it'll be considered floodable by a
from now on it's like we were living in
an imaginary world so so we don't want
to put our kids back in the basement but
now we can't leave we have to go back
then we had we are we have a very small
house and two of the rooms where the
basement and we have three kids so
anyway so now the only option we have is
to put a second floor on our house
because we can't we we have to go back
and we can't sit with no one's gonna
want to buy that house for at least five
six years right and and so it's like so
now we're so now we so that's what we
that's what we're looking at and I mean
thankfully people we've had some help we
had the GoFundMe was was pretty
successful so that'll be like a nice
like a nice starting point to be able to
do that but I probably and also I've
always been debt averse my whole life so
I have a very very small mortgage like
it's ridiculous how little my mortgage
is so I can probably borrow on my on my
mortgage and then rebuild so you know
Wow
yeah but it's it's even the dislocation
you know these things these things work
in us in weird ways and so yeah I
continue to pray for you and your family
thank you I keep telling people though
this is not the first time we were
evacuated we've been evacuated several
times but not with not the same this is
more like our kids are older and we're
well we also have to deal with their
emotional thing you know before that it
was like us we had to deal with it and
we had
very very smoky I didn't know what's
going on it's like they were just on
this trip traveling or whatever right oh
we can see are their youngest daughter
who just breaks out crying because she
misses her house and yeah and and and I
realized oh she's actually never lived
anywhere else yeah
now I've lived many places I've lived
all over all over the map but she's
never lived anywhere else so it's so her
attachment to that house is way deeper
than mine yeah yeah so that's that's
been something that I've discovered
which has been touching but also kind of
okay so I need to take this seriously
like I can't just be take also I can't
just treat this house like it's just an
object
I realized so there's history here I
need to I need to also consider that
with my kids you know at least deal with
it talk to them and no matter what
happens you know but I we're telling
them that that would add that house that
we lived in it's gone I mean although
we're gonna ma we're probably gonna go
back there it's not it's not going to be
that house it's going to something else
it's gonna have to for it for a child
that is a whole different thing than it
is for you and you're sure for sure for
sure yeah so but that's that's life in
this world and yeah exactly
that will be that will be something for
your kids that and this will be it this
will be a major event for your children
your lives it'll be something that
they'll always think about and it will
reshape them as they grow up this will
be something that for good and for ill
both unity it's and luckily we have you
know we take the time to sit together
and talk about it and explore you know
and so I think the kids feel like
they're part of the discussion at least
so yeah but you know you you it's so
weird it's like when you you're going
through that and then you look around
and you see you know I mean I I look at
Jordan with Jordans going through oh and
and it's crazy you know and so and so
you think okay life you know you you
always have to remember that no like
Jordan always says no matter how bad it
is it could always get worse yeah so you
really have to really have to approach
things in a different way so and and
Jordan has been a it's crazy I mean
right in the midst of you know him being
at the hospital every day and
think he'd write me little notes and say
how are you doing how's your family
doing it and I'm like Jordan don't you
don't have to pray me yeah you've had
your own thing to deal with you know
it's it's okay anyways yeah I I had I'd
sent him a note and just you know
expressing my concern and telling him
that I was praying for and and he wrote
back and he's a very caring individual
and and that comes through and and how
many of the times when he breaks down
when he talks about people coming up to
him expressing what you know great what
he's done for them but it's it's you
know a number of years ago when I was I
was I got sick as a pastor of doing
little series which is sort of the
Protestant way and so I started just
preaching through the Bible serially and
which allows deep dives into books of
the Bible and one of the one of the
things that I came out with was was this
little phrase that I I plagued my
congregation with which is the age of
decay because that is that is the
biblical sense of what we live and we
live in the age of decay it's not that
isn't reality but it's the age we live
in it's the govern it's the governing
paradigm we live within and that's a a
deeply troubling thing for us that that
houses go relationships go things we
build go and so it's and it comes to all
of us none of us none of us get out of
this world alive exactly exactly so how
about you how how are things how's the
your your I keep I keep being astounded
at how many videos you're able to put up
and I you know but and now what's great
is I can actually watch the videos of
the people that I know which is which is
which is intense so I saw you talked to
Sevilla and then you talked to Jeff
Phillip who's been part of our my like
little inner group that we meet every
month and we talk for for about an hour
just a small group of us like the top
patrons and we have this like this
little seminar going
I was really happy that you talked to
him because I really feel like he's a
very perceptive and very sharp so so
that was good he was he was he was so
much fun to talk to now it's it's been I
mean the last year and a half since I
started the videos it's been crazy but
it's been terrific ministry we just had
a meet-up last night my throat's a bit
I've had a whole bunch of meetups and
stuff lately so my throat's a little
worn out I guess but we had a so
Benjamin voice was in town and told me
that Benjamin ko so how did that go that
went great we had we had fun we recorded
some video yesterday I took him out for
dinner with my wife and so we got to
meet my wife and then we had a meet up
at church to meetups two days in a row
okay just because of scheduling and just
you know it's so funny because we have
these meetups and most of the people who
come are atheists but they they they're
surprised as I am that here they are
sitting in church and you know god
they're not as dismissive of the whole
thing anymore they don't believe but
they're just kind of curious about the
whole thing and then one atheist last
night was after the meeting so we have
the regular meeting and then the after
meeting and people kind of breakups into
threes and fours and conversations
continue and and he looked around he
says you know you you you're starting a
new church here I said well it's not
really a church right now but yeah you
got all these young men and so it's it's
been it's been phenomenal and the
conversations the individual
conversations I've had with people I
kind of paused them for a few weeks
because I've got vacation coming and I
have to have to kind of catch up with
something my goodness I imagine but it's
I I don't want to stop them and I don't
want to I don't really want to regulate
them in terms of me picking who I talk
to because the individuals that find me
and share their story with me that's
been that's been transformative for me
and so I this this whole journey has
been just phenomenal so
starting a new meetup groups and when
Jordan kinda hit his peak a lot of
meetup groups started a lot of those
have kind of fizzled yeah but mine my
group continues to grow and it's growing
now mostly with people inviting their
friends to the meetup and and so now
I've got a some of my pastors in the Bay
Area I'm kind of pushing them too you
know you should you should do this and
so we had another church that started a
new one and you know they had 20 people
in there first their first their first
night and the pastor you know the pastor
has some good skills he's the right guy
for it and I thought this will go so
it's been great yeah and but at some
point maybe that then the name of the
meetups will have to evolve yeah could
be find some mother because like you
said Jordan kind of he kind of exploded
now you reached his peak then obviously
for a while at least until something
else happens it's going to it's gonna
fade I mean maybe not who knows like I
keep thinking that he's reached the top
of what he can agree but you can keep
going but at some point you know it's
good like you said it's gonna fade like
a normal wave like any wave and so to
keep the momentum going I'm sure there
are ways to rename and to rebrand the
meetings because now this whole
discussion that's going on it's pretty
intense pretty interesting to see John
grab a key come in and and you and
myself and then there's people like
Sevilla who's extremely intelligent and
very perceptive and so I'm seeing these
people kind of pop up and I'm thinking
you know Benjamin voice is part of that
as well and there's other peripheral
people that um that are probably worth
kind of bringing in and getting into the
discussion but I think that fostering
this this type of discussion at this
level yeah that that could be a good
path for the future in terms of people
continuing the discussion even as Jordan
kind of you know moves on to something
else or whatever it is that he decides
to do yeah we need great for the
discussion to continue I've thought a
lot about that you know what are we
gonna name these groups and at this
point at least still Jordan's name yes
brings people brings it's weird it
brings Pete
all together with the right disposition
to have a conversation yeah and that's
and and then like I said now in terms of
my meetup here most of the growth is
from people inviting other people maybe
come and they and they're just it was
funny we had a guy named Tim who's
actually Orthodox and he's one of the
guys who really wants to bring you to
Sacramento one of these years with his
church and he says to me after the last
meeting said meet up Sunday night we had
a little group that we decided that
group was going to talk because he split
up into little groups we're gonna talk
about Jordan Peterson and he's like I've
been here four times and this is the
first time we've talked about Jordan
Peterson but people people bring up you
know sort of whatever's on their mind
but it always has had the Nexus of of
religion meaning just a lot of people
just coming to sort faith sort things
out it's a it's a place that they feel
feel welcomed and free to pretty much
ask anything and have it be you know
worked on both seriously but also you
know respectfully so it's for me I've
always you know there's this there's
this place in the New Testament in I
think it was in Corinthians when the
Apostle Paul rents out this Hall of
Tyrannis and you just a few verses and
basically you have the sense of the
Apostle Paul renting out this all and
people come in from miles around to talk
with him and discuss with him and you
know you have a sense of kind of a Mars
Hill thing where people are debating the
philosophies of the day not debating but
discussing in terms of their own
personal lives I've always dreamed to
have that the church would be a place
like that where people could come in and
and talk through their stuff yeah Wow
there's your dreams come true right
there it is it really is and you know
it's it's just crazy to me that well
here's this you know Canadian
psychologist who would make up and have
a fit about pronouns and somewhere along
the line that would
start something like that it's
incredible I I'm probably I one of the
some of the heat that I'm getting is
that I'm not doing anything in French
because French is my first language I do
live in a French place you know I live
in Quebec a French is the Ling language
I live in actually and so I will
probably I'm thinking of in this fall
starting some kind of meet-up of some
kind of talk to some people around me
that you know I've seen on social media
that I know are from the area and it
seems like you people are interested to
to do that and so I've also been
thinking like what what should i frame
it during Peterson or frame it meaning
crisis for I don't I'm not sure like I'm
so I'm trying to think of it but that
probably starts doing something in
French and at least in the fall because
it is a bit it's a bit it III have so
many prejudices about Quebec about where
I live it's a horrible like you know I
really have this this idea like I tour
what I'm gonna say is really horrible
but I really have this sounds like it's
totally lost it's finished you know it's
all over here and you know I so what's
the point you know what's the point in
in even talking to two people around me
which is so stupid it really is an
emotional like a very emotional
irrational thing that I that I develop
so I have to I have to kind of reconcile
myself and it's interesting because this
village where I'm staying
I mean we've stayed here because we had
friends who had were selling a house
people we knew were selling their house
and we ended up being able to get the
house for a while and now I'm
discovering that this village has this
massive historical cultural importance
it's almost been forgotten by the French
Canadians there's right next door to my
house is one of the most famous singers
in Quebec who's a who's like a very
elderly man but he was really you know
important part of the developing kind of
Quebec culture and down the street
there's a house of another poet fit
exactly who is extremely known and and
so now I'm learning that all these poets
and artists lived around this village
and so I don't know it's connecting me I
don't know how it's rash it's irrational
but it's kind of connecting me a little
bit to my roots and giving me more
desire to do some things in French and
to talk to talk to French francophone
people I
it's the Providence of God it's how you
know
I tell people you know people Americans
like to imagine that God is somehow this
you know that CS Lewis said this
benevolent grandfather it's like oh no
God God when he wants to do something he
can play rough and he can he can he can
flood your house he can you know it I'm
I'm curious how much of this crisis that
that Jordan sort of I mean the man in
the moment kind of found each other how
much of this is really tied to the
english-speaking world and so for then
the french-speaking world
how will this be different I'm really
curious I'm really curious too because
for sure there's something very
english-speaking about Jordan this whole
intellectual dark web thing this whole
enlightenment David Hume thinking it's
just not it's just very English that
this this idea of the individual the way
that Jordan frames individual it's very
very English and so I'm I am also
curious to see how it's going to at
least I don't know how this question is
going to be asked in the in French
circle for sure the people that have
been coming to me now just recently I've
had people kind of coming to me and now
maybe I might even be going to France
and doing some things in Europe it's
been mostly the symbolism part that
they've been interested in and kind of
recovering a coherent worldview and
recovering a a kind of symbolic approach
to life so that's been but the jordan
peterson stuff that i don't I didn't I
haven't met a lot of French speaking
people who have been interested in it so
I don't know if it doesn't totally
connect there's something about it I
don't know yeah strange there there have
been a fair number of Dutchman I've you
know when when when Jordan went to the
Netherlands he had a fairly good-sized
audience but the Netherlands I mean
there's such a small country and their
English is so good that they they seem
to tend to follow the you know the
English culture quite a bit yeah I've
had a lot of sweet Swedes write me a lot
of people in Sweden and so if
seems like yeah in the northern parts
for sure Jordan is having an impact so I
don't know yeah I mean it's funny get in
his 12 rules for life he just didn't he
didn't come to Montreal and I think I
think CAA did their homework like the CA
probably did their homework and they
realized that it just wasn't the place
like they would he wouldn't be able to
draw the type of crowd that he can draw
in Toronto and in other Canadian cities
that's what I think maybe not I hope
it's not secret French hostilities I
know Montreal and I know Quebec and the
rest of Canada have a very special some
disagreements yeah but he lived for a
while in Montreal McGill is his and this
is that's where he it's his alma mater
that's what he did is his first degree
so though he's he's attached to Montreal
so I was surprised at why he didn't he
didn't come to do the 12 rules for
Lightfoot I'll have to ask him one day
so so where do you think this this
meaning crisis conversation is going
Jonathan I really I'm excited to see I'm
definitely excited to see and it's
really pushing me also to talk about
things frame them differently and I'm
realizing that's really interesting and
I think it's the same for you where
certain questions that are perennial
that you've been asking or that you've
been talking about but all of a sudden
because there's this discussion you get
the people of rebel wisdom and you have
John reveille key and then you have
other people talking about the the more
spiritual part of it you could say or
the deeper questions you have people
like Ben Shapiro who and Jordan we're
having these discussions as well so I
think that it's it's forcing us to
reframe the the way we're talking about
it so that we can come to actually
discuss and so you know I always tell
people even the word consciousness
that's not the Church Fathers don't use
the word consciousness but I think it's
a perfectly appropriate word to use
because we all know what it means when
you use the word soul no one knows what
that word means anymore it's it's
everyone you know and so I think that
that to me that consciousness question
is going to be the one I think that's
going to be the most interesting to kind
of get to and the the the problem of
consciousness the
of how the relationship between
consciousness and existing within a
narrative I think that's that that's the
key that's the that's the key that's
going to to unlock a lot of problems and
and I hope that that's what you know and
that's the thing that John Verve a key
and I kind of we asked her a little
disagreement I mean it's not a
disagreement it's just we know that
we're on two sides of that question um
and hopefully we'll have some some
chances to talk about it there's a
there's a group in Ontario that want to
invite both of us to do like a public a
public thing and so I think that that'll
be that'll be interesting and also to
talk about to present to me it's also
been about rediscovering some aspects of
the Christian faith that have been
forgotten or lost you know that's why I
have chosen certain writers or certain
Saints that to talk about in order to
bring out the more cosmic aspect the
more the aspect which is related to
transformation to mystical experience
something akin to consciousness although
we like I said they don't use that word
I think that that that's the that's the
key to you know the Saint Ephrem st.
Maximus and Gregory of Nyssa there's
some writers that have really that
really give us a perspective on these
questions that we're having today
and they've been they've been a little
bit sidelined because people had other
issues too other issues that were
concerning them but now it seems like
it's right in there you know it's right
in the in the fray so I you know I I had
a so much I find so much fruitful so
many fruitful questions come from
interactions with quote-unquote regular
people I had a woman in my Sunday School
class asked me Sunday she said I just I
just heard a preacher that said you know
forgiving yourself is not in the Bible
and because that's a big mantra right
now and a lot of evangelical oh you got
to forgive yourself you got to forgive
yourself and I thought about it I
thought no he's right you don't find
that in the Bible and then I thought
part of the reason you don't find it in
the Bible is that the these subtle
relationships we have with consciousness
with how we imagined the self
I mean some of these things have
continued to change and and and we we
don't notice the changes until you know
something comes up and it's like well
look at this oh and I I think you're
right you know that the the focus on
consciousness might be a substitute for
the meet-up title for a Jordan Peterson
thing although that will bring that will
bring fascinating other interested
parties into the conversation as you
well know a lot more psychedelic like
who thought we would be having
conversations about psychedelics I mean
we do you imagine like three years ago
that you would be talking to people and
that's what you would be talking about
to me that was not part of was not on my
radar at all oh that totally took me and
and it was as so many of the people I
was talking to had been in that realm
and it's like how did I get here and
then when we started talking about it
the biggest surprise that I've had was
meeting people in my church who said oh
yeah I converted after a psychedelic
experience I'm like what I didn't know I
had no idea that I had never heard that
before well they're not gonna cough that
up and don't they're not gonna say this
like just straight up so oh it's true so
I you know I I agree I've been so yeah
this this whole thing has taken such
interesting turns and I think it will
continue to take interesting turns I
think a piece of it is that what a lot
of people new at towards the end of the
19th and beginning of the 20th century
that that materialism is pretty much
played out that's these things take a
long time to kind of filter through a a
culture and I think we're we're getting
to that point now that more and more
people will look at someone like like
Sam Harris and the the kinds of ideas
he's promoting and just say it's that
and I you know and it's interesting
because we had a last you know this the
new atheist wave was like this last care
resurgence of that movement you know
they it was a lot shallower than you
know someone like me chairs or the
hardcore you know these kind of
philosophical 80s that you find in the
end of 19th century so you have this
kind of care control moment where
everybody is somewhat seduced by it you
know all these people they went all the
way you know all the way into that I
spent at least Harris talks about
consciousness and it's talking about a
little bit about first-person experience
but people like Dokken for example
completely oblivious to any of that is
it ignores completely the fact that he's
a person in space who has an experience
he does that's not even it's not it's
like no it's like he's abstracted
himself from the world and thinks that
he's looking at it you through this
objective scientific lens and so I think
that as that caricature comes to it
reached now its end then it's an
opportunity like it ends up being a
great opportunity because suddenly and
you see it I'm sure you've seen it too
you you see people you see it in their
eyes
that they've understood that secret it's
it's almost like a magic thing that was
just veiled in front of them they
couldn't see it they just couldn't
understand what was significant about
that and then all of a sudden it's like
oh yeah wait a minute what do I do with
consciousness like if I even if I ask
even if I try to encompass it back into
the scientific system then it whoa then
it creates very strange things because
it's like okay so I'm you know how does
it it can't just be this thing atop that
we ignore pretend that it's just we take
it for granted all of a sudden it has to
to to be dealt with and so it's that's
been the most that's been to me the most
fascinating thing is to watch people
understand that and so there's like okay
now you have that you've had that
glimpse you've had that awakening moment
okay now let's take you what's step by
step I'm gonna take you step by step and
show you what that means you know what
it means in terms of what a story is
what it means in terms of of you know
what a frame of for reality is what it
means in terms of necessary necessary of
hierarchy all these things are gonna
come back in yeah and then I'm going to
show you
in the Christian story why things are
the way they are like why is it that we
talk about things the way we do you know
because that's that's the normal world
right the normal world was this is the
world in which the first thing that you
that you encounter is this conscious
experience of being and the and then on
top of that you can add you know the
rationalization you can add this this
analytic mode it's fine
but in the frats not the first it's it's
never the first thing I think it will be
interesting to see I think there's a
crisis in Protestantism that and you see
this in in some ways in the renewed
interest to the more sacramental
liturgical traditions you know the one
of the things that I obviously can't
miss is how many people coming out of
the Jordan Peterson conversation are
very interested in in orthodoxy and I
think orthodoxy partly in America
because it's unlike their vast
experience with Protestants unlike some
of the some of the corruption and and
chaos that has been in the news in the
Roman Catholic Church orthodoxy is sort
of the new kid on the block at least in
this continent they don't have their
hands dirty they haven't had any big
scandals only bad skin you know though
we've had scandals for sure yeah but
they're not known but I think I think
yeah there's a little bit of the I
always kind of joke around and think
that there is in orthodoxy enough of the
foreignness because the the the the
foreignness is dangerous and but it's
also an opportunity right it's dangerous
because it can kind of it can it you can
project into it and know and you see
people do it I see it a lot of people do
with Buddhism you know it's like they
just project whatever they want and do
Buddhism it it's like it's everything
that I want it to be just because you
don't know about it you don't really
know what it is you know it's like
actually look at tantric Tibetan
Buddhism and you might be surprised and
what you find but anyways and and so I
think that orthodoxy has enough of the
foreign to to to attract the attention
to kind of titillate and
you know kind of surprised because we
were other things are banal you know but
it's Christian you know it's not it's
not it can connect you back to your
origin also through that fascination and
through that kind of surprise it
hopefully can connect you back to to the
Western story too you know so so I
that's what I've I get that sense a
little bit so I don't know tell me a bit
more about how you you you've seen it
well I see this as a crisis
so I've been reading more in the
referent about the Reformation lately
and paying particular attention to these
these terms of consciousness and so you
know what happened a lot with Luther is
this the sacramental system that
medieval Roman Catholicism had you know
continued to work there was so much
corruption that on one hand you know
that was that was clearly a complaint
against the church all the corruption
that was happening which which the
church which Protestantism forced the
church to have to address but then also
with Luther there was this change in
terms of the relationship between faith
and consciousness that that faith became
very much of a psychological reality
much more than a a an embedded reality
in terms of materiality and I mean you
see this with all of the different
changes that happens with Protestantism
you know the really and an individualism
comes into play in Protestantism and
this these things happen slowly because
people don't just you know change
overnight with this and Luther who's at
the center of it I mean the the chaos he
unleashes surprises him because karlstad
who was right there with him you know
goes off into the radical and it's
basically spawns the radical Reformation
and so so chaos ensues but you know one
of the things that I see now I was
having a conversation with with other
people in the Christian Reformed Church
because obviously the same sex marriage
debates are are just running through
Protestant denominations and and they're
having to wrestle with it but one of the
things I noted to a
actually a Canadian scholar in the
Christian forum Church is is that in
some ways this when Protestants when
Protestants basically say you know using
the Bible the Bible as such is supposed
to resolve any any question that comes
to the church and what has happened with
the questions about women's ordination
the questions about same-sex marriage is
that Protestants are basically the they
they've they've they've given up looking
to the Bible to resolve these questions
now however people feel about these
questions in the Bible I'm gonna push
that aside what's what's interesting to
note is that the protestant vision was
that here with the Bible we can answer
any question and Protestants are giving
up on that and so then you have to ask
well what if Protestantism and and
they're kind of in this point where they
it doesn't seem they can go back to
Catholicism and so okay if the Bible
can't resolve this with respect to the
community where do we go and so I think
I think we see a a continued crisis
within Protestantism and and I think he
I mean if if in the Reformation we saw a
turning from an embedded sacramental
vision of of a universe made whole that
the sacramental system was supposed to
embody into a much more psychological
phase just like we're seeing the end of
materialism we're seeing the end of that
merely psychological for Protestantism
and so in this new phase which I think
is going to attempt to reimburse nough
sand materiality in one coherent picture
that's you know prior Protestantism has
been a fan effect of this this division
and what do Protestants do and I think
that's that's a completely on
answerable question at this point right
yeah what's the what's the solution and
I think that the I mean it's interesting
because in terms of the Bible I've been
thinking about this for quite a while
because when I was young I I was in a
very conservative you know Protestant
denomination I was a kind of
conservative Baptist and and it was all
the Bible like you said it was like the
Bible the by midnight and I had no
notion of liberal Protestants like I had
no idea like I never but then when I
finally discovered this whole you know
piss Kop alien kind of direction I
realized so Protestants both let's say
affirm the Bible you know as the Word of
God that kind of language and then
they're also the ones who destroyed the
Bible they they did both and and there's
something about there's something about
doing one which leads to the other I
think you know I I was having the
discussion with a even with the
Protestant Reformed pastor a while ago
where he kept saying the Word of God the
Word of God and I was like the Word of
God is Christ and I was like I tried to
get rid of to get back to that and is
like because if the Word of God is or at
least if you if you had this idea that
when you say Word of God in terms of the
Bible you it's somehow equivalent to
when you're saying the Lord divine logos
like in that sense then that's going to
break apart because it the Bible itself
is a it's a garment it's a garment of
skin it's a it's a it's a it's a it's an
outer covering and and so because of it
it it's a material thing like a it's a
it's a series of words and letters and
phrases and it's because of it it it can
be broken apart it has to be held by
something above it it has to be held by
the Holy Spirit you know it has to be
held by the the unity of of the church
it has to be held by the unity of the
faithful in the Spirit of God or else
it's going to start to fragment it it's
going to start to be poked at you know
and even in the very desire to prove its
validity in a kind of materialist way
that you're going to destroy it and that
it seems like that's what happened where
all these scholars and scientists who
wanted to prove that the Bible was this
and that and this started to scratch
added the details of it finding these
little loopholes and holes and oh this
text isn't like this this this this old
manuscript isn't like this one and oh
there's differences between the
manuscripts and oh wait a minute and you
know this whole section we don't have in
this manuscript of a sudden it's like oh
and finally you end up with the Bible
that has all these little different
colors you know like little paraphrases
and little notes like this text is not
in so many manuscripts ourselves like
that's not a Bible that's a at least
don't use those Bibles in your church
because that'll destroy your church have
a Bible that has all these these notes
in them anyways so it's an interesting
and I think that I think that ultimately
it's not like it's not the sacramental
system right it's not the sacramental
system it's more seeing the the unity of
the church and the Holy Spirit as being
the first the first place where God
encounters the person right is the
Pentecost is Pentecost comes before the
Bible right Pentecost
precedes the Bible and we tend to see it
in terms of systems like in terms of
bishops and whatever and satin like you
said like different sacraments but the
at least in the Orthodox tradition we
tend to talk about sacramentality in
general you know not so much
not that the sacraments are important of
course they're important but there's a
there's a kind of a joke that people
talk about where when the the eastern
fathers encountered the Latins for the
council of florence you know in the I
think it's in the 1400s the the
Catholics asked the Orthodox how many
sacraments there are in the Orthodox
were like what do you mean how many
sacraments there's like there's seven
sacraments they're like what do you mean
is seven didn't understand the question
it was like sacramentality is just a
whole process of how we exist in the
world and how our existence in the Holy
Spirit transforms reality and how it
transforms things and so it's as much
the prayers it's as much the you know
like we it's it's the objects in terms
of the icons and the prayer and the
church and all that but then
it's also the manner in which we live
together like that we we exist together
as a as a communion of saints so it's
it's a bigger thing you know it's like
it's a bigger thing than the system of
sacramentality I don't that makes sense
oh that makes perfect sense yeah well
and Protestants have always had this
propensity to to to divine eyes the
scriptures and kind of you know so you
have the Father Son and Holy Scriptures
as your Trinity instead of this is what
I mean this is what's happened in
Protestantism again and again and and I
think part of it was in in the West in a
sense so quite clearly in the
Reformation scripture replaces the seven
sacraments and and the Bible itself
becomes the only sacrament and you see
that in the in in both what happens to
baptism which right away you have a big
fight over baptism because the the
understanding of what baptism is and how
it functions divides in the Protestant
church and and then with the Eucharist
like in a similar way it splits and so
you have Calvin with his with his real
presence who's trying to maintain some
sense of of sacrament and you have the
the aunt the you know Zwingli in
tradition that's as well it's a it's
sort of a symbol it's a sign but it's
nothing nothing really happens and and
so again you see that it's it's just
bound up with these deep assumptions
that that theological language attempts
to express and philosophical language
attempts to explain but then the way the
Bible then gets handled one of the
things that that I noted when I was when
I was in seminary even in the eighties
was that for a long time in the West the
church wanted to make theology a science
okay a science in the new sense of the
term science now yeah yeah not ciencia
right a science and then the Bible then
was
just like for a a chemist chemicals
would be the thing that the chemist
works on or a theologian the Bible is
the thing that we take apart and and all
of this had its you know a lot of it had
its beginnings in Erasmus when Erasmus
of Rotterdam comes and looks at looks at
the Vulgate looks at Jerome's Vulgate
and begins to some you know more and
more Greek texts are around and so he
begins to look at so well why is this an
and there's this whole movement that's
saying no the Holy Spirit inspired
jerome to write the Vulgate as such and
and see right there you have the
beginning of this of this thing people I
remember being people tell me that the
King James Version is inspired like
they'd inspired by God oh that's exactly
right and so you see this happen again
and again in the West they were
approaching the Bible now I think what's
going to be interesting is you know so
when John and ver Vicki and I spoke we
had a conversation last week you know
what so when I listen so so it was very
interesting listening to Sevilla because
she she's talking about for Vicki and
you and I'm kind of watching this and
saying wow she's seeing some things and
she's seen some things and between the
two of you and and I this question of
return mm-hmm
and and I you know when I think about
what's next I I don't see I don't know
where product Protestants have in some
ways ever since the Reformation been to
work off your current situation they
they've in a sense been homeless in some
ways and so they've been kept trying to
establish homes hmm and and they're
gonna build their own homes and typical
Protestant fashions we ever nobody else
got this right except us at our little
group so I I don't know what it I don't
know what this what the new what this
new turning that we're seeing now will
mean for Protestants if you know clearly
many are going going back to
you know but but in some senses they
don't have one I had one colleague say
to me you know if if if the east and
Rome ever make up I'm in yet II and so
in a sense the Great Schism then comes
into play in that I don't know if I can
go back to Rome or the east because they
can't get their act together yeah that
for sure that is definitely I don't see
it I to be honest in the eschaton but I
want to come back to the sacramentality
question I my question to you is let's
say now with this this this kind of new
perspective on consciousness and on
patterns let's say on on patterning and
how the the innovate innovate how it's
inevitable that there's patterning in
our human engagement patterning in the
way we frame the frame since the world
frame our narratives all that you know
if I would say something like in that
there's a hint of sacramentality in a
handshake could you see that that that
that could then be in a hierarchy of
sacramentality which would lead to to
communion which would lead to the the
Eucharist as let's say the the anchor of
the world something like that or the
anchor of the church but then that also
then filters down in and it helps us
also then to understand how we are
constantly engaging in in symbolic in
the sense of condensing right in
symbolic actions between amongst each
other but then also when we frame our
own story our own narrative were acting
in this kind of symbolic way and all of
that has a ultimately sacramental
process you know we were talking about
this is something that someone asked me
in a Q&A once at a at an event actually
and I it really struck me when I when it
when they said it because it just I knew
it but it's one of those things where it
was formatted in the right way when they
said if you
do like Christ says which is if you see
the good in the other and you you always
looking for the good and the other and
you're always looking for Christ in the
person in front of you
won't that then transform reality for
you won't that actually make it will if
you if you participate in that and you
let yourself go and you actually don't
look at people's faults those faults in
a certain manner will will be diminished
they'll be lower in the hierarchy of
attention you could say and and in the
end the hierarchy of attention as you're
engaging with others the world will
actually become more glorious it will
become it will fill up with light and
you see that because you see people who
everything they look at they always look
at the negative they they they always
see the negative thing no matter what it
is because it's always there it's
inevitably there it just depends on how
you structure it in that that kind of
hierarchy of attention so so to me that
that it explaining of that way to me is
it is a way to say this is what
sacramentality is about it's about that
but then it it doesn't it also does
include baptism marriage all these
gestures that we pose because they're
the most condensed version and if you
take baptism for example it's like if
that's the story this is it this is the
go down to the into the water go down
and get you know get the spark you you
go down to the water you leave your
garment you're dead garments and you
come out you know vested in in Christ
and so it's like that's that's it doing
that actually is a transformative thing
it's not it's not just a it's not some
whoohoo magic it's like it actually
that's how the world works you know
through those types of gestures it's
just this one is so condensed and
symbolic but every time you you like I
said like every time you shake someone's
hand or you say hello or you do that
you're you're participating the same
process right right and actually the
conversation I had with with Ben
Benjamin Boyce yesterday very much
touched on he has the recording so I
don't know what will come out of it but
we this is exactly where we went because
he you know he's he's he's working on
his own journey and so he picks at you
and me and Verve a key at that end of it
as opposed to the the two other themes
that he works on in his channel and you
know he asked well you know where where
can we so so when I listen to people
like Benjamin and many many other people
I talked to its they always focus on
wealth where can I find this experience
and and what they're what they're sort
of saying is that they're imagining that
this experience is going to be something
akin to again a psychedelic trip and
that and that somehow in this special in
this special experience that somehow
where I will meet God and so I I post I
gave him the Isaiah passage where the I
say is in the temple and the Seraphim
are there and they they cry out holy
holy holy is the Lord God Almighty the
whole earth is full of his glory and I
thought I said you you will you know you
will you will encounter God you know you
walk into Yosemite Valley and everyone's
like well there's his glory and I said
you know even after a meet up we
finished our two hours and then we take
our little picture and I do that to kind
of break the group out of the table and
then they all break down and I stand in
the church and I watch clusters of two
three or four people having clearly
meaningful conversation I say well I see
his glory there and and in fact this I
think I love the way you phrased it
because it is sacramentality we see we
see him all over the place and it's in a
handshake it's in the child it's it's in
my encounters with with the homeless
it's it's not a separate you know here
I'm going to go into a trance or take a
psychedelic drug and oh in this special
little place that's where I see God
because he's not everywhere else no he
is no and this is where I get you know
you mentioned we should talk about God 1
and God to God one is the whole earth is
full of his glory there's you you you
keep bumping into him not just when
you're you know when chemicals are
rushing illuminating your brain and
you're in some ecstatic state
you bump into him with the embrace of
your wife with you know and even that
I'm elevating it too far with sitting
down for a for a meal and you know all
throughout and and so this is this is
part of what I think is I think this is
a function of the question of
consciousness and materiality mm-hmm and
and that we have taken we have said well
spirituality is this unique set of
things over here
and no not just when you're on a
psychedelic or not just when you're in a
service and sort of flushed with the
majesty and the beauty or if you're
Pentecostal when the Holy Spirit
descends on you not just those places
but but that then but that then triggers
people in terms of the pantheist
conversation because when they hear that
then they say well God is everything and
no not that's not it either
yeah and and well well why can't you
just tell me I don't know idea that the
earth is full of his glory I think that
that's that's it like that's the way to
see it that that the glory of God fills
up holds is the secret behind everything
you know it's the thing that's hidden in
the world and and if you with the right
eye you can encounter it you know and
and I think that there are you know if
you read the there is the possibility of
a deeper transformation you see it I
mean three the lives of the saints you
do have this idea of a a kind of
illumination that they are transformed
that their life is transformed that they
participate in God's nature that it is a
kind of ecstasy a kind of ache a you
know a kind of rapture but that doesn't
just come to you like it's not it's not
an experience that you go somewhere to
get it's something that you that you
encounter through a life of a prayer of
of contrition of you know of confession
of all these these you know and of
loving your neighbor and and and doing
living in the life of God then you you
approach those those moments if
something like that is just given to you
I think that it you know there's
something counterfeit about it there's
something dangerously counterfeit about
it and and you know the church fathers
and modern fathers they warned us about
kind of pseudo spirituality you know
this the simplistic experiential
spirituality that you can that you you
just have these experiences and and you
know if an experience doesn't transform
you doesn't make you love your neighbor
more it's pretty useless I mean it might
be fun you know but it's not it's not
that's not the point right it's the
there's something it's supposed to
transform you yeah well and I think you
know what happens with a saint is if a
Protestant may use that word the point
of Protestantism in territory right but
the point of product Protestantism is
that we all sainthood is not for a
special class of people over there
sainthood is is God's desire for all of
us yeah and when and I'm sure you've had
this experience too when when you meet
someone who has in at least in your
estimation and in your experience
achieved a degree of sainthood you begin
to notice that for them the world is
much more the world is very alive and
the world is very alive with God and it
isn't just in with these separate
experiences I think actually the D drive
to locate God only with certain kinds of
elevated experiences or flow States or
ever we might want to say it is is part
of this instrumentality that I think is
at the heart of the meaning crisis yeah
Owen Owen Barfield who is a very
interesting guy in wrote about this
quite a bit in the middle of the
twentieth century and one of the points
that he made was the the degree to which
we explain is exactly the degree to
which we lose meaning and and I think
what's what's the key thing in that is
in a sense our instrumentality because
the desire that we have for mastery of
nature is directly related to the our
our ego if we if that's the right term
or our consciousnesses desire to I I
think live idolatrous Li which means
that we are going to turn the entire
world into our slave yeah so that we can
secure for ourselves the outcomes the
experiences the the patterns we wish
yeah instead of actually receiving the
patterns the gods patterns it's the
heart of the rebellion in the garden
yeah for sure yeah and and I think that
that's you know the whole self-help
culture all of that stuff is exactly
what you're saying and and a lot of
modern this kind of California Buddhism
is that as well there's a it looks like
I'm going to I'm going to to to meditate
I'm going to do these these these
different things it's like it's just
like a technique I'm gonna do it so that
you know so that I have I have more
energy I have you know I feel better I
am a happier whatever and so so there is
this this kind of instrumentality like
you said and and I think that that's
maybe you know that's interesting
because that is something that I think
when you talk about the problem with the
meaning crisis and it was interesting
because I I kept seeing that that's what
Bishop Baron was trying to talk to
Jordan Peterson about majority this
wasn't it just wasn't on his horizon he
kept trying to bring it back to worship
he was saying it's worship that's the
key key is its what do you celebrate
that's how it starts it's it's like what
are the things that we celebrate and
that comes way before all the other
questions of like you said this this
idea of I'm going to to use this
technique of this technique to achieve
this goal in my life or whatever the
first question is what we celebrate and
that's something that that
I thought that the fact that he kept
wanting to bring you back is like it's
about worship it's about worship it's so
hard for people to understand that the
the attitude of grab the attitude of
gratitude and the attitude of of
celebration of worship that's the first
ground to to reality and that's the only
way that you don't make God an
instrument you don't make God into
something that you're going to use to
get what you want is is true worship and
and true you know like you recognize
your place like know where you are and
and and elevate celebrate that which is
is the on you I think the difficulty
that Jordan and almost everyone I talked
to has when we when we try to lay this
out as we usually do what people hear is
okay well this means that it's if you're
if you're orientation is instrumental
all you see our tools hmm and this is
deep in what Jordan I think articulates
very well in that that which is in us we
are looking out at the world with a
perspective and that perspective shapes
the world that we see and so if we if we
see ourselves as consumers if we see
ourselves as masters of the world
everything everything we see is a tool
and and then when you come to someone
and say well write worship what they
hear is the church as a tool by which I
can find meaning in my life find
happiness in my life and so they go to
church as a tool and thinking about the
church as a tool now the church is going
to provide these kinds of things for me
and then they go into church with that
attitude and well it doesn't work
because it doesn't work exactly and and
that's exactly so if you talk to people
who have you know given up on the whole
thing
well they they will tell you again and
again it didn't work right whereas when
listen to you and Bishop Baron and how I
know you to be you don't go to church
because well I've you know gosh you know
my house just got flooded maybe you know
maybe I wasn't praying hard enough to
keep the flood water as a par and so now
I'm going to go to church to to to give
you know to get my blessing yeah and and
in in a sense because of this consumer
and it's way even before the consumer
this instrumental approach because it's
the heart of idolatry that they can't
help but turn church into an idol
whereas it in a sense you don't go to
you you certainly go to worship to have
yourself reorient ed my god yeah I'm
gonna say right you don't go to church
in order to well shoot I better go to
church because my wife needs
straightening out and my kids need this
and I need more money I mean you don't
do that I'm sure I do sometimes there's
some times where it's like a yeah
because the thing is the the thing that
happens is that the lower aspects that
you mentioned this idea of finding some
kind of stability finding some kind of
relief even in terms of in terms of
confession or or you know finding
legitimacy or finding there's all these
things that actually you do end up
getting but like you said it's that but
you you'll only get them if you don't if
you don't look for them if you don't
look like that and and that's true about
so many things in life right it is true
about about about so many things like it
it's like if you if you go into a
friendship only thinking about what it's
going to give you then you're going to
get a lot less out of that friendship
then if you go into a friendship with a
kind of open desire to connect with
someone into to to you know to have a
communion with a human person then the
gratitude that say them the lower
aspects are going surely gonna get way
more you know and Christ you know Christ
always says that all the time he's like
it don't worry about the things of this
world
don't if you don't if you if you focus
on God if you celebrate that if you
celebrate God if you live in the kingdom
of God then you'll get those things
don't worry they'll be there like that's
not the point that's not the point of
life well and and I think what happens
in the Enlightenment is we're so
impressed with our success being
intentional scientific consumers that we
have able we have been able to achieve
electricity levees flood insurance air
conditioning we have been so impressed
by this but Jesus says if you gain the
whole world but lose your psyche I mean
I think what Jesus is saying right there
is basically he's saying here's the
meaning crisis for you you've made an
exchange yeah exactly
you are living comfortable consumer
lives with air conditioning and all of
these things but you've lost your soul
yeah and it's fascinating to hear people
wonder and you hear people it's like how
is it why is it that we have all these
great material things but our society
you know the social fabric is eroding I
don't understand it's like wait a minute
didn't Jesus tell you like didn't I mean
hasn't it just been one of the
presuppositions about the basis of
Western civilization that if we focus
ourselves on those you know those
smaller things then then we'll lose the
higher one you know it's like you you
have to orient yourself properly well
and I think for for both of us we had
experiences earlier in our life of going
and living with very poor in very poor
communities and one of the things that
would happen is North Americans would
come to the Dominican Republic and they
would meet the Haitians and the
Dominicans sort of like you know touring
going on Safari with you know we're
gonna experience some Haitians and and
one of the things that the Americans
comes through and say they're so happy
now first of all they you know they're
polite and they're hospitable so they're
not gonna oh here's a stranger level and
let me tell you about all the troubles I
have in life now they're they're they're
people with social skills they don't do
that but I think that experience that
north and wealthy North Americans have
of oh they're so happy
is I how can a person be happy living in
desperate poverty in you know with with
none of the material success comfort or
security that we prioritize so highly
how can they live without that and
actually live normal human lives yeah no
I agree I agree I I wanted to look as we
wanted to talk about God one God to so I
want to try to get to that before okay
where we got to run out of run out of
run out of breath so uh maybe because I
think that maybe I'm over interpreting
your god one in God too because to me
like the way that I I see it is that
they're the same like to me they're dead
and I think you think they're the same -
um and and but I think that maybe to me
I don't see them as being opposed or as
being as being distinct to me one flows
out of the other in the sense that that
would you talk about God
number two flows out of God number one
that's right and you could you could say
something like the the manner in which
the infinite encounters the particular
right is going to the Saracen assistant
will necessarily look like will it will
be will there is no other way for the
infinite to encounter the particular and
and so that's going to and it's going to
be adjusted it's going to be an answer
to of specific it's not going to just be
the infinite right it's going to be an
encounter and therefore it's going to be
an answer to a prayer it's going to be a
a it's going to be something which seems
to shift things in a way that that you
might not understand it's going to be
something that's going to open up things
provide opportunities good all of that
is going to happen it's going to be it's
going to look like will because that's
the like I said it's it's only because
we think we don't consider the idea of
being or consciousness we don't consider
we think that it's not that it's not
part of somehow not part of the universe
that we that it's or it's some it's some
epic phenomena despite the fact that
it's by that that we actually understand
everything um but as soon as
consciousness comes back in you could
say it's the same about even you right
that you have you have a your person is
somehow your soul your spirit or
whatever you don't totally have access
to it it's actually something which is
which is higher than your usual
conscious self that is something that is
that is kind of above there and then
that will come down and express itself
in specific will specific specific
desires and sometimes those can be can
be not in communion with each other
right they can they can actually be in
conflict with each other because you're
not United but if you can imagine an
infinite and the infinite God then those
wouldn't be in in in conflicts they
would actually be United and that would
be God's will and it would be God
answering prayer and be all that all of
that to me just it just makes sense it
could be it could even be miracles it
can be all this stuff that that we talk
about God number two God acting in
history to me flows out of of the God
number one then you talk about I don't
know I don't know if that's something
it's the way you think about it or that
makes sense to you I agree with
everything you just said okay and I came
I came up with this because I was
watching I probably watched that thing
20 times that the exchange between
peterson and sam harris in the first
vancouver debate because the the night
is wearing on and they haven't really
gotten to the god question in Sam's mind
hmm Jordans been talking about it the
whole time Jordan Jordan knows what he's
doing in that conversation he he's
putting together an argument and he
keeps trying to build something and
Sammis sort of keeps kicking it over
with all of the usual tropes that sam
brings to these debates yeah and so they
get to the end of it and they're like
well we haven't talked about God and I'm
thinking you've been talking about God
the whole time and so Sam says to Jordan
tell me what you mean by God and Jordan
sits
down and begins to talk to lay out all
the ways in which this this impersonal
filter and the assumptions that we have
which are necessary to function
psychologically to to break down a a
world which is far too large for our
little brains to hold together and the
ramifications of that for daily life so
Peterson has this he sits down with this
computer he opens it up says I'm gonna
read these because they're they're
they're so complicated and he starts
reading through them and Sam then
interrupts them and says no no no no no
that's not God and and no that's that's
not what God means and I'm thinking well
Sam doesn't know any history and he
doesn't know any theology and he doesn't
have any understanding of holy holy holy
and the whole world is full of his glory
so what and and that I think is helpful
because so in the West and Bishop Baron
and Peterson talked about this - that
God sort of gets fragmented and
especially in the Protestant Reformation
and kind of blows apart and and part of
this blowing apart I was trying to
articulate with God number one and God
number two in Christianity there
obviously together now you actually see
towards the end of that conversation
that Peterson goes to God number two
when he has is sitting at the edge of
the his bed and going you know asking
this moment of repentance that he lays
out for Sam Harris but but this is in a
sense well what happens in the West is
the when God number one and God number
two kind of get pulled apart and this
happens in providential deism where
where we say well nature is and and even
when we use this word nature mm-hmm um
nature is this thing that's separated
from God and and there are that this
gets so complicated the word nature
it's completely flipped around use the
word nature today as is the opposite of
the way that it was used you know it
traditionally it's hilariously and so
nature so that's another thing I became
paying attention to every time someone
says nature I think what do they mean by
that word yeah and and what they mean by
that word is something without
consciousness or intentionality
something mechanistic yeah yeah there
you go
that has that is what nature someone
dies of natural causes as opposed to a
murder
you know conscious agent willfully
interfered with what we imagined to be a
mechanistic playing out of the world
where there is and only when you have
that kind of view then suddenly you can
split God up and send him away but what
Jordan in a sense does with his God
number one is he says okay let's give
Darwin his due and say we don't need a
god to make the world but in a sense
what Jordan is saying and I think in a
deep way is you can't have psychology
without God well what kind of God well
this this God number one but you're
exactly right in that once you and I
think this is why we see people who and
it's not conscious for them but people
are listening to Jordan and Jordan is
smuggling God in to the conversation and
that is leading people to God number two
hmm because yeah I remember that moment
in the sent one of the SEM Ayres talks
where Jordan mentions this idea that if
you ask you know if you ask something
you'll get an answer and sam says yeah
I've done that it works and it's like
but that's not God it's like what what
where am I like what world where am I
like you asked and there's an answer and
therefore there's a there's a will
there's a there's a there's a something
presents itself to you as a formed
response you participate in that
just like you participate
in in in your relationship you know with
the infinite obviously it's going to
manifest itself in a way that is
appropriate to your to your frame that's
though that's the whole idea and so I
was like I just thought that was the
strangest moment when he said basically
it's like Sammy is saying that he prays
and he gets answers but he doesn't like
God it's like okay let's just find
another word if that's all that's Bob
it's just the word that's bothering you
let's just get rid of the word maybe but
that is the heart of our rebellion yeah
that is that is that that is in a sense
Adam and Eve saying the Satan suggests
well God doesn't have your best interest
at heart what that saying is God isn't
love and doesn't love you and therefore
you know when I when I listen to people
and I think what really is at heart of
the motivation to banish God from the
world even the psalmist no ancient
person would say there is no God because
that was just silly what they say is God
is absent doesn't see doesn't care won't
hold me accountable that's what the fool
says the fool the psalmist says says in
in his heart and and so though what I
find when I listen to and this this even
comes to the the complaint about
Calvinism which I hear often because I
you know say I'm a galvan which is what
gives God the right to make decisions
about me and I hear that and I think
it's it's just nuts because tell me tell
me how you are the house most of you is
the product of your choices it's it's so
naive yeah you didn't choose when you
were born to whom you were born you
didn't choose the genetic makeup you
have you didn't most of your life if you
don't choose but to say well God somehow
thinks he has the right to make
decisions about my life it's like well
you know that's because you think that
God is a guy that's like you you know
what is that horrible song like
that God's coming back home on the bus
or something like these horrible ideas
about about God as just as a and it
really comes with this whole is this
whole weird multi-dimensional idea you
know this whole idea this horrible idea
Alex Jones types idea where this idea
that that the spiritual world is like
another world like it's like another
dimension and and God is like in another
dimension it's like as if God is a being
and people have lost the whole idea of
principality the whole idea of
hierarchies of beings it's all gone it's
all on it's all level you know and so
they don't they don't imagine angels as
as as principalities they imagine angels
as just beings that are there in space
but you can't see them and you know
maybe you could see them and then they
could take a chat with you it's like
that drives me insane and so I think
that when I hear people talk about God
that way I keep thinking I keep getting
angry because it's exactly it's like
you're taking the lowest version of God
that like you know the most uneducated
person believes in and you're you're
arguing against that it's like I don't
know it I don't know who you're arguing
against I mean at least it's not me at
least it's not any of the Church Fathers
or any of the of the classical theists
it's Jerry Falwell I mean I'm horrible I
didn't say that anyway some you know
some just like kind of anyways well but
but so some when I was talking to
Benjamin Boyce yesterday I was saying if
you look at the Ten Commandments and you
look at the commandment God gives which
when you this commandment alone should
make people stop and say there's
something special about the Bible and
this whole thing you know Judaism that
leads to Christianity because when God
commands you may not make an image of me
from anything that I have created what
what that commandment says is you cannot
reduce me to anything that you can
represent
with your mind now this puts us in a
problem because in order to relate to
God
we need representations and Jesus comes
along and says father and and I thought
in with Nathan Jacobs had a conversation
with Hank Hannah Graf I thought
Nathan Jacobs laid that out well in
terms of how the father's talked about
father son and and that relationality in
other words we need representations in
order to relate and so Jesus gives us
one hears father but but every such
representation comes with its comes with
its vulnerabilities and liabilities but
but right at the beginning God says do
not represent me with a calf with a big
statue of a man with with any graven
image because once you do that you setup
exactly what you just described and
exactly what we've done and so what
happens when in a sense God number one
gets banished by Darwin what what
Christians begin to do because oh gosh
you know there was way too much sunk
cost in Christianity God number two this
relational what if God were one of us
this this relational imagination this
relational representation gets expanded
to fill the void and you see this in a
books let's say like Chuck Colson's born
again where here's a guy all his life
going to be Episcopal Church comes home
after meeting with a born-again
evangelical and says I'm a Christian and
his wife says but we've been going to
this Episcopal Church forever I mean
what was that about
no I know Jesus I have a personal
relation and so it's in a sense God
number two expands to make up for the
God number one that Nietzsche declares
has been killed and so you know
obviously I don't believe that there is
this division in God but in terms of our
represent representations of God this is
I think is something that has happened
in the West and this helps us understand
why Jordan Peterson lays this stuff out
sam harris says oh no that's not God who
would complain about you know
masturbation or what you do with your
body and then they go into this this
interesting conversation where Jordan
basically says and and I'm thinking
about doing a video on this week Jordan
acts as if God number two is real and
the reason be and I think you laid out
exactly why that can't be helped it is
the only way we can actually give God
right praise mm-hmm
so I that's that's for me you know why
God number the language of God number
one and God number two I think was
helpful for explaining some of what has
been happening you know where where
these discussions aren't connecting like
right where they're not and I think
you're right and I totally agree and I
think that you know because of the
because of people like Sam Harris and
the preponderance of that's an
evangelical discourse in in North
America I think that you know way that's
probably why also then I've talked more
about your like the transcend that you
know they're they're the infinite aspect
of God and this is this kind of you know
this idea that it's like the earth is
full of his glory that type of
representation but I also think it's
it's absolutely inevitable that that
will then become will like it will
become a will and will become all these
things that that you kind of associate
with with with God number two you know
this idea that God can reveal something
to you that you can that you can have
you know that that God can help you do
can redirect you that God can all this
stuff is to me is just is an inevitable
consequence of of God number one but
also inevitable consequence of re
understanding the world through
consciousness we understanding the world
through you know the supremacy of of
consciousness like the fact that you the
filter all of that is is is inevitable
you know sorry and and this is exactly
what we've seen happening and this is
exactly why the celebrity atheists are
completely wrong about what happens when
people give up their organized religion
and and I always use this commercial
that was on a few years ago from I call
her Verizon Lisa because this is Verizon
commercial where this woman walks in
front of a Verizon store and and the
universe told me Lisa you need a new
smartphone and by the way your hair
looks good today
and and this is exactly what happens
with people they say I can't believe in
God and so now they're not gonna use
g.od but they're gonna use universe
universe I know that is the most
hilarious thing it's like the universe
spoke to me like dude universe doesn't
speak okay things that speak we call
them beings we we have give them names
we don't we don't use a we don't use a
object description for things that speak
that just doesn't make any sense it's
like my hat spoke to me like your hat
doesn't speak the universe doesn't speak
but people people me and that's
hilarious yeah but it's that is exactly
who we are and that's exactly why the
vision of and Petersen gets at this with
Matt Dillahunty when they start talking
about his lawnmower you know and and
Petersen knows this the the difficult
thing is and here's the problem and CS
Lewis nails this when he talks about
pantheism because CS Lewis says what
happens when you play you know basically
when you start when you pray into the
void and the void speaks back and you
realize well what if what if this isn't
you know a figment of my imagination
well we know we have active imaginations
and we project as much as yes for sure
but and this is Lisa's Lewis's point
what if you desert what if you decide
that well maybe universe has designs on
you that you haven't been that you
haven't been asked to consent to that
yeah but this is the story of humanity
and it's right there in Genesis and it
goes all the way through and this
doesn't end because the the
heart of the heart of our rebellion is
that God is God and we are not and this
really we really hate that that's
probably want to be we want to control
the world we are all Sauron you know
looking for a way yeah yeah and did you
think like my my wife is it is amazing I
admire because she's able when someone
says the universe and they'll say the
universe you know I asked the universe
whatever she doesn't flinch at all she
just she just it's like in her mind she
just replaced his universe with God and
she's totally engaged with the president
I have this like little glitch I'm like
oh don't like that doesn't mean anything
it it's not it's not it's not a how can
you say I think I had the discussion
with David fuller when he asked me about
the universe and I said the universe the
fact that you can say that the universe
is one that you can use the word
universe that you can say it all just
that you that is pointing to you to
something my friend is point of you to
the to the notion that you can unify
that you can unify all of manifestation
and so there's something that pops up
above it like it just happens you know
universe how can you say that
it's a there's something above it
inevitably well and I think I mean for
me you both you and Jordan have been
extremely helpful for for helping me
recognize the indispensability of
hierarchies because we all I mean again
once once
Benjamin releases the conversation we
had and and he talked about the social
justice thing and how you know certain
people are saying they're creating kind
of a little island of privilege in that
what I am oppressed instead of I think
therefore I am I am oppressed therefore
I am or am black therefore I am and and
what they have to do is establish a
little one little space that they won't
deconstruct and it's like well there you
go there's your there's your Idol right
there and and the way you know gosh you
guys have you know I always keep this
dollar bill on my thing to you know look
at the little pyramid with the
separation of
because here's the thing once you
violate that third commandment and make
the the thing that cannot be
deconstructed into the top of your
hierarchy you have now created a
hierarchy that cannot stand yeah and
that's it yeah you're right and it will
fragment and it will splinter inevitably
yeah and you cannot actually have a
community around it because well I am
black well that means everyone who is
not black can't be part of your
hierarchy and you're going to have a
supremacist structure and and I think
just recognizing hierarchy is is
fundamental in this but then you bet but
then you get into the fact that what
happens with Christ and I realized this
a number of years ago when I was going
carefully through the gospel of loot is
Christianity is this amazingly subtle
working through of of equal and
hierarchical it's it's just back and
forth and you see Jesus so so what rebel
ISM actually came to Livingstone's
which was a hierarchically a
mind-blowing experience that a British
film crew would come to this church and
the one thing that oli noted in my in my
sermon that kind of caught his attention
was you see this with Christ because
he's at the top of the hierarchy and he
says I'm at the bottom
I am servant of all yeah that's why
Christ is not at the top of the
hierarchy it's not the right way it is
the right way to see it but you also
have to say that Christ fills the
hierarchy that's what he does he's
actually he's actually the entire
hierarchy yet so so it is right to say
that he's at the center he's at the top
all of that is fine but you need to
really understand that he fills it up he
goes to the bottom to I mean the descend
into Hades the crucifixion all of that
is jamming the entire world into one
crucifixion is insane you know it's like
jamming the entire world into one event
you know where the top and the bottom
completely meet you know where where the
mockery of Christ declaring him the king
is an actual declaration of kingship you
know where it's like all of it smashed
together the story of the crucifixion is
it drives you drive you insane if you
think about it too much but I want
to get to this idea that you said
because I think that that's one of the
things that like for example Jonathan
hight gets wrong is that he's understood
circumambulation he's understood this
basic pattern but he thinks that you can
just put anything there and
circumambulate that's not how it works
it doesn't it's not true you can't put
anything there that the thing that you
put in the middle has to have the
quality of the middle you can't just put
it you can't just put any random thing
in the center because if you do then
that's going to break apart it's going
to break apart either in let's say in
itself or it's going to break apart in
the fact that it's going to cause war
between the different the different
parties like it's going to it's going to
create the pagan problem where it's like
the fight between the gods where the
gods are warring amongst themselves you
know and so that's that that's the the
the supremacy of the let's say the
monotheistic tradition is that we've
come to a point where would we put at
the highest is the highest right it's
like we've said okay yeah okay so this
that you know it's like okay so the
these gods these gods these gods and
then we know the God is the highest is
the is the origin of all the God is the
the infinite is the thing by which all
things exist and so it's not the God of
War or the God of this or the god of
that no we've we've brought it all into
the the the the thing by which
everything exists so it's like we're
circumambulating the highest thing by
its very definition right it's and
that's why I always get annoyed when
when when people like Sam Harrison and
them say you're an atheist you just you
just not you're all the believers are
atheists they're just atheist towards
other gods like you can't you you you're
you're being dishonest in comparing you
know Mars with the the absolute with the
you know with the the the the absolute
transcendent God it's those two things
are not the same we're not we're not
talking about the same thing and so so I
think that that's that's maybe one of
the problems with but I mean oh it's
great that that secular eight
have understood at least that
circumambulation is the manner in which
the world exists they've they've kind of
seen it but they saw this flat disc of
this flat way of looking at it I think
that one of the best illustrations of
that I've come across recently as you
know who Scott Alexander is star slate
codex he has a blog he's a he's a
psychiatrist the East Coast he writes
Sudama pseudonym and suit anonymously
and he he wrote a piece recently rod
rear peaked it up as well it was called
gay rights our ITES our civil rights our
ITES he was in guatemala and noticed
there easter pageantry and he compared
that with kind of traditional american
civil religious 4th of July parades and
to the Pride Parade in San Francisco and
he was making the point exactly as
Jonathan height does that what these
parades are doing is functionally
equivalent to Jonathan heights
circumambulation mm-hmm but what he
can't see is exactly the point that you
just made that that which you elevate
and celebrate in your parade is not just
well we need a glue to hold society
together the glue matters stand and and
the difference between a Paschal
procession and and a pride carnival and
it's and and they appear in the very
manifestation of the two like one looks
like a carnival one looks like a orderly
procession of you know and so it's like
you can just look at what they look like
and you can see that one is on the edge
and one is actually turning around the
middle one is is a clown you know kind
of there's a difference between Mardi
Gras and Easter and yes we're not able
to tell the difference anymore with like
okay we think they're the same right and
and I just want to say Jonathan I have
learned so much from you and your work I
think is astoundingly valuable when
first yeah I mean I stumbled into this
old Jordan Peterson thing gosh how did
that happen well Scott of course but you
know but and and then you know well
there's this there's this Eastern
Orthodox icon carvers land just a random
guy and and I some of the first videos I
listen to you I'm just thinking what is
he talking about
and but after a while I began to say oh
wow oh wow I have learned I have learned
so much from you and I'm I'm really I'm
deeply grateful and indebted to your
work because it I mean and so many of
these things that you have that you have
Illustrated I think so well have have
helped me see a lot and so if if if
there are moments that you say why am i
making these videos well means like that
talking to these random strangers and
asking me cred I I look at the kinds of
questions you're asked in your question
answer videos sometimes it's like oh
gosh I'm glad I a part of the reason I
haven't started a question-and-answer
thing is like I don't I hope they don't
ask me the kinds of questions they ask
Jonathan I don't know if I could answer
them but I'm deeply grateful for your
work it's not only very touching but it
does you know to hear that from you you
know I really it's very helpful like
it's helpful like you said in those
moments where I'm like okay what is
going on am i doing I'm a youtuber you
know as I hear my kids I hear my kids
tell their friends that their fathers
are youtuber and I'm like oh but my wife
and oldest son actually have a phrase to
try to make sure people don't watch my
videos they're like well so I hear your
father's on YouTube it's like yeah he
looks like to our videos about religion
and philosophy and once people hear that
like but I've also I'm also really
impressed I think like I'm also
impressive the fact that you've been
able to kind of reach out to just the
everyday Liz
I don't know you do it like the fact
that you're able to have all these
conversations with all these people that
are watching your videos it's like
you're taking people on this like
therapeutic
reconnection you know taking them taking
their hand and kind of guiding them
slowly towards towards God towards the
church but in such a just a real
therapeutic way you know it's it's a yes
it's pretty it's pretty amazing it's
like hopefully yeah hopefully all of
this like this whatever it is that we're
doing like you know discussion this
weird thing that you know it's like yeah
anyways I let's just say that I think
that I think both of you I'm very
grateful as well like I'm grateful to
see that to see people come to you and I
hear people to all the time like they
days like I listen to fall everyday I
send to Paul every day and it's like
kind of like yeah they don't go to
church yet but it's like Paul's my
pastor they'll say things like that you
know we're there but they don't go to
church yet but it's like they know they
kind of know that it's in their future
they kind of know it but it's like yeah
you know I'll get there but for now you
know so so I think that that's awesome
I think that's great yeah thank you well
I one of the talking
it takes a lot out of me because it's
intensive listening that you have to do
for people they don't know I wouldn't be
that it takes a lot out of you because
it's like if you keep going like this I
don't and and this is I mean be crazy so
one of the guys in our Meetup you know
he was before Jordan came to Sacramento
he was ready to kind of kiss Jordan
goodbye because he was he was kind of
done with the whole thing but they went
to the VIP thing and and I he and I had
the same experience because he's he's a
psychologist and I'm a pastor
we watched Jordan work that hundred
sixty line of VIPs who had paid to shake
a SAN and get their picture and how he
was able to maintain you know listening
intensity with each person that came
through that line I I know what it's
like to work a line and I I can't
imagine how he's able to do that how he
was able to do that on his book tour
night after night that's that that that
was phenomenal i I couldn't imagine it
because
I love the conversation with randos as
they call themselves because every and
here's the crazy thing about human
beings you know they are their image
bearers of God and every single person
that comes to me especially if they can
just tell their story and you know many
of the stories I can't publish because
they're too personal and it would
involve parents or children or something
like that but it's a it's a like we said
earlier it's a holy thing that becomes
holy ground where you know where they
they share the pain and the tragedies
and the victories of of common life and
it's I mean God is God has been all over
their lives and they haven't recognized
them sometimes or seen him and as the
the the great privilege of being a
pastor is to is to steward those stories
and and hopefully allow others to see
God through the stories of ordinary
people that's that's one of the things I
learned from my father and his ministry
and I think he learned from his father
and his ministry so I I have to figure
out how to do that in a sustainable way
so well anyways it seems like you're
succeeding in my in my perspective
because I I couldn't like I think that I
yeah vennett so so I think at least for
sure the fact and even even if you tell
me also I didn't know that a lot of the
videos you're not putting up so it means
that you're having even more
conversations than the ones we're seeing
so that's pretty cool I think it's great
well people are that people are image
bearers of God and and even if they're
far from God or can't see God anywhere
God's glory is you know their life is
littered with God's glory and and God is
working in the things that they don't
see and it is a it is an amazing thing
when when they come to a place where you
know suddenly
they came around a corner and oh my
goodness there's there's God and it's
the CS Lewis pantheism quote and okay
well what what do I do now yeah that's
exactly right what do you do now hmm
when you find the burning bush do you do
you you know run away that's a
reasonable thing when you hear the voice
that says take off your shoes you're on
holy ground well the best thing to do is
obey but we're we're messed-up creatures
or something all right Paul I think I
think I think we this is the longest
conversation we've had I think like
almost two hours
so I you know I didn't want to you know
with with everything going on in your
life I didn't want to bother you with a
conversation but I I still enjoy you
Jonathan I love your laugh your get you
have this weird giggle that you get to a
point
[Laughter]
laughing the words I would my problems I
laugh in the worst possible places the
reason why I did I did a video on
laughter where I kind of I did a video
like it's like the meaning of laughter
or something and and I was pretty harsh
on laughter I think it's also just
trying to understand why I laugh when
things get weird or when it gets anyway
look I'm happy if there if it's
enjoyable yeah so anyway thank you
Jonathan alright I do appreciate this
and yeah you recorded it so you know
whatever you want to do yes I recorded
it and I think I missed like the very
beginning cuz we've started right away
and then it's like oh wait I need to
record this so I'll see I'll gonna see
how I edit do you what do you want to
put up on your channel as well sure all
right so what I'll do is we have a lot
of people in common yeah we do have some
that are so we should probably both post
it so I will send you I'll send you the
link and yeah and so I think that yeah
that'd be great okay plan another future
discussion and hopefully at some point
we'll speak at the same place you know
that'd be great
I am I am talking to this one church
that that would really love to have you
out and so then if that happens maybe we
could do some joint things and and I
when I talked to John for Vicki maybe
the three of us should do a three-way
video at some point - that could be fun
that could be a lot of fun yeah
definitely definitely all right Paul all
right Jonathan okay there all right
bye-bye
if you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out if you're not subscribed
please do go ahead and share this to all
your friends if you can get involved in
the discussion we have a Facebook group
in which people can talk about these
subjects I will put all those links in
the description and also if you can
please support us financially by going
to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com